this is the binary mechanical adder and
this was one of the very first
innovations that was
designed by danny hillis for the ten
thousand year clock this solves a very
fundamental problem in trying to keep
time over the course of ten thousand
years in that it relieves the clock from
having to use gears to do all of its
calculation over that amount of time the
problem with using gears to do your
calculation as very traditional clocks
do
is that as the gear teeth mesh they wear
a little bit of material away each time
and as that
wears away they go around and around and
they're becoming less and less accurate
with every revolution and it's a very
minute amount but over ten thousand
years
you can imagine that that adds up and so
you have this additive error problem
danny hillis whose background was in
computer design realized that there
might be a way to use binary mechanics
in a way similar to modern computers to
do
digital
math with analog
components
and so
what we have here is a is a wheel that
every time it goes around it reads a
program a number that's programmed in a
binary way with pins and then
writes out
a a version of that number
on the outside in bitpin levers that it
can switch and once it adds that number
up it actually gives an input or an
output to the dials so that it can
advance a dial and these can be
programmed for any dial on the clock or
any planet that we want to show and in
fact he designed this based on that same
way that
they do calculation and it's a it's a
binary system in that it has pins that
are programmed in either zero or one
positions on the inside and then it has
what are called bit pin levers that
actually flip from zero to one based on
the inside program every time this
wheel goes around
so in effect what you get is digital
accuracy with the reliability and
transparency of mechanics